differences between male and female
friendships how they relate how they
bond why they make up and break up what
can predict their friendships the
Dynamics of the relationship the way
it's built up and maintained with women
that is always conversation based
because they're always focused on
engaging in a kind of discussions of
emotional content and relationships and
the social world on a one-to-one kind of
basis what keeps women's friendships
going is the frequencies which they can
do that the amount of times of
conversation has zero effect on men's
friendships and that's because their
friendships their social world is built
around activities my iconic example of
boys bonding is usually a lovely picture
of two old Greek men sitting in the
sunshine outside of Taverna every so
often they would pick up their coffee
and take a sip and put it down they
never said anything this is boys bonding
I mean you have to talk to people to get
things going but actually once it's
going what's really important is doing
stuff together and conversation then
becomes much much less important